photo 100% little person the ones that
bomb you mine okay thanks
say green you want to grab one with me
I'm a man your whole face he's even
saying no he doesn't I don't want a
picture with he's going to know you feel
bad thank you very much Oh hi
everyone it's Charlie Marvel has
released a couple clips of Hulk during
Avengers end game sort of explaining
what's going on with his ending how
professor Hulk works within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe compared to a comic
book professor Hulk in what his future
is going to be in the Marvel movies
because while everyone's bummed out
about Iron Man and Captain America not
being the traditional version of Captain
America anymore
Mark Ruffalo actually still has one
Marvel movie left on his big contract
that he signed a long time ago meaning
that we will definitely see professor
Hulk come back during Marvel phase four
in a big movie so I'll explain what
that's going to look like based on the
Marvel movies that we know already
happening during Marvel phase four and
there was a really cool deleted Hulk
ancient one seen during Avengers in game
that we just found out about that I'll
breakdown so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos they'll be crazy
Easter eggs flying around this summer
between spider-man far from home the
multiverse what Mysterio is doing then
the big Comic Con panel will we get the
big phase 4 schedule in d23 later this
year I know there's a lot of questions
if we're ever going to see world breaker
Hulk in any of the Marvel movies because
professor Hulk is sort of the more
sensitive chatty version of the whole
the brains of banner in the body in the
strength of the Hulk
just a couple other versions of the Hulk
in the comics that are really notable
that people are wondering if we're ever
going to get a chance to see so I will
address that during the video too but
think about it this way Mark Ruffalo
signed a six picture deal he did
Avengers Avengers age of Ultron thor
ragnarok Avengers infinity war in now
avengers endgame that's five movies even
though there's been cameos cameos don't
count towards the actors films on their
contract first things first though
everybody's asking is his arm going to be
completely messed up for the rest of his
life because the current day version of
Thanos his arm was still messed up when
we found him they went to him on
that new version of Titan that he
created so then does that mean that it's
also going to be the same for Hulk going
forward even though he's super smart he
could probably find a way to heal
himself for now it does seem like his
arm will be permanently damaged going
forward even though he was still able to
fight with it like that during the big
final battle you see him here during
that big Avengers Assemble moment with
that big smile on his face so even if it
does really hurt like his arm is
probably permanently going to give him some
pain he only gets stronger the matter he
gets so his deformity in a way will give
him a little bit of an edge
but that arm will always be weaker than
his other arm so yes it will be a
disability for him but not quite as much
for Thanos not so much that it'll be a
really huge problem when he appears in
future Marvel movies but think about it
this way these are the Marvel phase four
movies that we know about so far in
where the Hulk would be able to show up
again we already know about spider-man
far from home doesn't really seem like
he's going to be in that movie and even if
he does have a secret cameo like I said
the cameos don't count towards the films
on their contract so he still has one
major starring role left the next movie
after that is going to be the Black Widow
solo movie which they're shooting right
now you've probably seen some of the
behind the scenes pictures of that but
it's very clearly set in the past she
has her traditional red hair she doesn't
have the mixture of blonde in red that
she had during avengers endgame and Hulk
even says when he's sending Captain
America back you know man I really tried
when I snapped everyone back I tried to
get NAT back but the stones wouldn't let
me do it so this is their way of saying
that the current version of Black Widow
that we've been living with this whole
time she is not coming back but that
doesn't mean that other alternate
reality versions of Black Widow couldn't
come back and future Marvel movies like
Secret Wars
then there's the Eternals movie after
that which is going to be said thousands
of years in the past so clearly Hulk
isn't going to show up during that then
the shang-chi movie can't really put
professor Hulk in that because why would
you need a smart version of the Hulk in
a shank Chi movie he doesn't really fit
their peanut-butter-and-jelly style like
thor ragnarok it's not going to be like a
buddy comedy movie the important thing
to remember is that if he's going to be
professor Hulk forever going forward
then it would have to be a movie that
will require a smart version of the Hulk
so if you have a whole bunch of other
smart people already you don't really
need the Hulk
there's guardians of the galaxy 3 as
guardians of the galaxy as far as we
know for now but they already have Thor
and Adam warlock to introduce so they're
probably not going to have room for
professor Hulk to have a big role during
that which means that that won't count
there's the Captain Marvel sequel but
that also kind of seems like it's going to
be set during the past after the events
of the first Captain Marvel movie just
set later in her timeline out in deep
space so at that point in history Hulk
would have not made it out into space
yet so there's no real point in putting
him in that one either that only leaves
a couple of the movies that we know
about there's the Doctor Strange sequel
doesn't really seem like you need a
smart version of the Hulk in that either
because supposedly the villain is going
to be nightmare
per the directors earlier comments after
the first Doctor Strange movie I really
liked the character of nightmare and the
concept that the nightmare nightmare
realm is a dimension I always thought
that was one of the that's early that's
like in the first strange tale I think
that's in the introductory episode
of Doctor Strange and I always loved
that that's the director just talking a
little bit about his ideas for the
sequel does doesn't mean the villain is
confirmed to be nightmare from the
comics it could be anybody because they
have access to the x-men Fantastic Four
characters now really hoping they find a
way to work Mephisto into the Doctor
Strange movies at some point but they
knew a black panther too and obviously
it doesn't really make sense to put a
smart version of the Hulk and that
because you already have Shuri who's
supposedly even smarter than that in
black panther has enough technology to
negate any benefits to having a really
strong smashy version of the Hulk he
already has a lot of tech that can
replicate a lot of the strength of the
whole so you don't really need to bring
him in and I think they're trying to
keep the Black Panther movies relatively
self-contained two characters that work
really well in that genre but that only
leaves Avengers 5 in a possible Young
Avengers movie the Kevin Feige has
hinted at like we have the stature
version of Cassie Lang teenage Cassie
Lang at the end of Avengers endgame in
much all the movies that are said in
present-day now will take place after
the events of Avengers endgame so that
means it's year 2023 so when we get to
the next ant-man in the wasp movie it
will still be teenage Cassie Lang unless
they do some big surprise and do a movie
set during the past which I don't think
is going to be the case it just doesn't
make that much sense they haven't said
when Avengers 5 is going to come out or
if they're going to wait till Marvel phase
5 to release that they haven't specified
when they might do a young Avengers
movie either if that be later in phase 4
but they do say that it's something that
they're working on right now I wouldn't
be surprised if they waited about three
years for the next Avengers movie bare
minimum three years just to give a
little space between the end of Avengers
endgame and clear the dust a little bit
before we introduced that brand-new
roster of Avengers with some of the old
ones coming back but also introducing a
bunch of new ones the really cool
deleted scene with Hulk in the ancient
one that we learned about is because of
a really big change they made in the
script to the way time-travel works in
the way that she explains how the
Infinity stones affect the flow of time
so during that really cool scene where
she phases him out of himself and you
see the astral form of banner coming out
of professor Hulk and they start talking
about it what it seems like happened in
the original version of that scene that
they had to later reshoot was that the
ancient one didn't specify how the
Infinity stones affect the flow of time
so she didn't make it seem like they
would create alternate realities by not
bringing them back they needed a lot of
that logic to sew up how you explained
the version of Loki that gets away with
the tesseract because that's still an
alternate timeline that continues to
exist after the end of Avengers end game
whereas Captain America takes all these
stones back to where they got them from
so all these potential alternate
realities get sewn up like he had to
take the soul stone back to Vermeer so
that he actually had to interact with
the Red Skull and even though so much
history passed between them I would give
almost anything to actually see that
scene between the two of them when he
took that back but for those of you
asking about him taking the soul stone
back wouldn't that also then reverse
what happened to Black Widow and bring
her back by consequence the way the
directors and the writers explain it and
they kind of disagree on a couple things
but they do agree that you can't get
back the sacrificed black widow to the
soul stone they haven't completely
explained the logic of it only
that is sticks there's no way to bring
her back even though Captain America
puts that soul stone back beyond that
Mark Ruffalo hasn't said anything about
whether he wants to continue as the Hulk
within the Marvel movies he's one of the
few actors that hasn't publicly said yes
or no so it's a bit of 50/50 as to
whether or not he's going to continue being
Bruce Banner after the events of his
next Marvel movie he hasn't done the
Chris Hemsworth thing yeah where you see
Chris Hemsworth going around doing all
these interviews for other movies like
Men in Black talking about future Thor
movies yes I totally want to do future
Thor movies I would totally love to be
in guardians of the galaxy 3 as if he's
trying to be really funny pretending
like he has no idea whether or not he's
going to be in the next guardians of the
galaxy movie despite that Avengers
endgame post-credits scene with him
joining the guardians of the galaxy on
the other side of that he has not done
the Chris Evans thing where he's made
like he definitely wants to leave and
stop playing the Hulk
so if for some reason he decides to not
resize his contract after whatever next
Avengers 5 movie that he does what
they'll probably do is just because from
a toy sales perspective not even from a
story perspective within the universe
Hulk sells a lot of toys little kids
love Hulk so of course they want to keep
a version of the Hulk in the universe
they would probably introduce she-hulk
Jennifer Walters or an Amadeus Cho
version of the Hulk so that you could
still have a Hulk with in the universe
even if it's not going to be Bruce Banner
but then for all of you wondering if
we'd ever see a world breaker crazy Opie
version of the Hulk they could bring
Mark Ruffalo back to do multiple
different versions of the Hulk during a
Secret Wars multiverse crossover movie
that's where you could bring back the
chatty more sensitive Professor Hulk
version of Bruce Banner but you could
also do a separate reality version of
world breaker Hulk pitch is completely
off the chain there'll be a really easy
way to pay off another joke like you got
when they went back to the events of the
first Avengers movie during endgame and
he's all embarrassed by the previous
version of himself like oh look at me
smash and all that stuff you also
probably heard that news that Keanu
Reeves wants to join the Marvel Universe
and being a Marvel movie is a big
character now he said a couple different
things separately news sites have been
reporting that Marvel is officially
courting him for a role in a really soon
upcoming Marvel movie but that's
supposed to be Eternals which I Kai said
to set during the past so when people
were asking him
earlier separately whether or not he
would ever want to be in a Marvel movie
he said yeah sure he basically said that
he wanted to be the new Wolverine I
would totally love to be Wolverine but
obviously Kevin Feige said they're not
going to be doing that stuff right away
it's going to be a couple years before you
start seeing x-men pop up in the MCU
films and even though he doesn't look
like he's that old he's in his early 50s
right now and when they recast a new
version of Wolverine he'll probably be a
much younger actor who can play the
character for 10 plus years the thing
about the Eternals movie though is that
even though it said thousands of years
in the past the characters are literally
eternal they live almost forever Thanos
isn't eternal that's why he's so
long-lived - he ages the same way that
Thor ages but he's a little bit older
than Thor so even though you might have
Keanu Reeves showing up during the sea
turtles movie whether or not he chooses
to actually sign on for it he could
still be alive in present day and show
up in future Marvel movies during
present day during a big Avengers
crossover but I love the idea of Keanu
Reeves showing up in the Eternals movie
with Angelina Jolie no idea whether he
would play a hero or a villain but let
me know in the comments what's the next
movie that you want to see them put
professor Hulk n in the Marvel Universe
during phase four and who do you want
Keanu Reeves to play in the Marvel
Universe we still got that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway going on all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I'll
name a winner in my next big Marvel
video there'll be a lot of spider-man
far from home trailers dropping in the
next couple weeks because we're about a
month away so just look out for that as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see all the videos when I
post them while you wait for everything
click here for that brand new spider-man
far from home trailer watch him make his
own spider-man suit and click here for
all my Avengers and game Easter Egg
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!